alors bonjour à toutes et tous je
m'appelle don qu elle la mort j'ai 26
ans et je suis chef d'orchestre
compositrice et arrangeuse donc une
chose qu'on m'a souvent dit au cours de
ma vie même si heureusement je l'entends
plus trop aujourd'hui c'est des discours
dans le genre de quand est ce que tu vas
trouver un vrai métier
il serait peut-être temps que tu fasses
de vraies études etc etc etc
donc aujourd'hui je vais vous expliquer
comment petit à petit j'en suis venu en
quelque sorte à m'inventer mon propre
métier et à toujours faire exactement ce
que j'ai toujours voulu faire sans
aucune concession
même si au départ la chose que je
voulais faire et ep est peut-être pas
évidente mais je savais pertinemment
qu'elles étaient les choses que je ne
voulais absolument pas faire donc pour
remettre dans le contexte
moi je viens d'une famille enfin d'un
environnement proche et familiale où
tout le monde et freelance ou
professions libérales et tout le monde
travaille soit dans le milieu dollars
soit dans le milieu de la culture
mon père est sculpteur mon oncle est
peintre ma mère était styliste etc etc
donc les exemples que j'ai eues en
grandissant c'était des gens qui en fait
ne pouvait dépendre vraiment que
d'eux-mêmes et la seule certitude qu'ils
avaient c'était qu'ils adoraient ce
qu'il faisait et il était vraiment
responsable que de même et surtout il
avait de comptes à rendre à personne et
au bout du compte dans cette famille je
suis la première musicienne
donc moi je dis souvent que j'ai pas
choisi la musique c'est plutôt elle qui
m'a choisi quand j'avais 5 ans je me
promenais avec les parents dans les rues
de paris et je me suis arrêté dans la
vitrine d'un luthier il y avait un petit
violon pour enfants et j'ai fait une
crise absolue pour que les parents de
l'achète donc ils m'ont acheté mais
monter la condition c'est que tu fasses
des cours et que tu apprennes à en jouer
donc je les fais autant vous dire que ça
n'a pas vraiment été une histoire
d'amour j'ai absolument détester à
prendre cet instrument et j'ai laissé
tomber
à peu près deux ans après mais mes
parents y la lucidité de voir que
c'était peut-être pas mon instrument
mais par contre la musique c'était
vraiment mon truc
donc ils m'ont dit va choisir notre
instrument et là je me suis dit ah bah
le flamenco c'est super cool j'ai envie
de faire la guitare donc j'ai commencé
la guitare classique
j'en ai fait un peu plus longtemps que
le violon mais c'était toujours pas ce à
quoi je m'ennuyais un peu je voulais je
voulais autre chose donc quand je suis
arrivé au collège
là j'ai commencé la guitare électrique
et il a le déclic je tombe à fond dans
le rock surtout américains des années
soixante à soixante à quatre-vingt
j'enchaîne les groupes avec des amis au
collège au lycée etc et en armant il se
passe quelque chose d'autre c'est que je
commence à tomber à fond dans le hip hop
au site et via ça je commence à vraiment
m'intéresser à la notion de de prod quoi
de beatmaking donc grâce à youtube qui
pour moi est un des meilleurs
professeurs j'apprends à utiliser plein
de logiciel de composition de séquences
de séquençage et de production musicale
ça s'appelle la et mao la musique
assistée par ordinateur donc durant
toute cette période qui s'étend en gros
du collège au lycée j'ai cette notion un
peu évidente qui s'impose à moins que la
musique va faire partie de ma vie et que
c'est ça que je vais faire plus tard je
ne sais pas exactement encore ce que je
vais faire dans la musique mais je sais
que je vais travailler là dedans c'est
sûr et certain
parce que pour moi c'est en train de
devenir quelque chose qui est aussi
essentiel que le fait de respirer
donc pendant que j'ai cette vérité qui
un peu s'impose à moi quoi je suis au
point où le système éducatif et qu'il
faut que je commence à m'orienter
c'est à dire qu'il faut que je commence
à décider quelles vont-être mes études
supérieures et surtout quel métier je
vais faire après ces 10 des études
supérieures sauf que ce système en gros
vous dit que la seule chose qui en gros
me passionne m'intéresse la seule chose
où je sais que j'ai envie de faire sa ba
je pourrai jamais en faire un métier
en fait c'est juste un passe-temps est
un hobby et faudrait peut-être que je
trouve un autre truc donc la seule fac
ont inscrit c'est une fac d'archéologie
bon je suis pas allé donc là je me dis
ah bon qu'est ce que je fais donc de mon
côté je tâtonne un peu dans l'est dans
les écoles privées de musique parce que
conservatoire c'était hors de question
j'ai étais jamais allé donc qu'est ce
que j'aurais fait là bas je n'aurais pas
pu suivre et les écoles privées de
musique j'ai un accueil très mitigé
il y en a une par exemple où je passe
l'audition et les deux professeurs qui
la faisait passer me disent ouais on
sait pas la musique
t'as pas l'air hyper motivé je critique
c'est ok bon on va voir ailleurs encore
une fois et j'avais j'avais j'ai la
chance que vous paierez américain et il
me dit bah tu sais quoi vu que t'es
américaine aussi t'as qu'à essayer de
voir ce qui se passe aux états unis au
niveau des écoles peut être que tu
trouveras ton bonheur et il avait raison
quand je commence à regarder ouais les
programmes ont l'air top hyper ouvert et
on peut apprendre plein de choses donc
je fais les démarches et je fini par
rentrer dans une école de musique
actuelle en californie où je m'inscris
en spécialité guitare donc hop je prends
ma valise juste après le baccalauréat je
traversais océan je débarque à los
angeles
et là c'est un peu la révélation parce
que je me retrouve dans un endroit où je
suis entouré de gens qui sont un peu
comme moi c'est à dire que les autres
étudiants ils ont le profil un peu jour
spécialiste de rien mais passionnée par
tout et surtout c'est des gens qui
veulent vraiment bosser et à prendre et
donner le meilleur d'eux mêmes et là je
me dis ça y est je suis au bon endroit
donc je travaille absolument
d'arrache-pied je comble un retard
énorme que j'avais parce que bon quand
j'étais en france je n'avais pas accès
ce type d'éducation et je suis comme un
poisson dans l'eau et vers la fin de mes
études il ya un de mes professeurs qui
me prend un pari kenzy tu sais quoi
franchement lâche rien parce que je
pense que tu seras sûrement une des
élèves dont on entendra parler plus tard
et là je suis hyper contente parce que
c'est la première fois que une figure un
peu d'autorité qui
me donne de la validation tout cas la
fin de ce cursus bas je me rends compte
que j'ai encore une fois un petit souci
c'est que la seule option qui s'offre à
moi c'est que je peut que devenir
guitariste professionnel c'est-à-dire
enchaîné les tournées et les sessions
studio et j'ai pas vraiment envie de
faire ça j'ai envie de plus de quelque
chose d'autre
et par hasard un peu complet je me rends
compte qu'il ya cette école qui
s'appelle berklee qui est très connu aux
etats-unis c'est considéré comme une des
meilleures au monde qui fait des
auditions à la fin de la semaine au bout
de marge
donc je me dis ah bah on va y aller on
verra bien de toute façon ça peut pas
être mal donc j'y vais et à ma grande
surprise je suis acceptée en plus il me
donne une bourse pour aller étudier je
me dis ah bon maintenant il faut que j'y
aille
donc je prends mes valises je passe de
l'autre angeles à boston de l'autre côté
et là je me retrouve dans une immense
écoles ou encore on peut étudier plein
de choses différentes
donc je me dis bon ça va être l'occasion
d'étudier un truc où j'y connais rien
tant qu'à faire et je vais étudier
quelque chose où je pense que ça va
vraiment me servir et aussi je vais
étudier une spécialité où les techniques
que je vais apprendre auront résisté à
l'épreuve du temps
donc je choisis composition classique et
là je deviens un rat de bibliothèque
je passe tout mon temps à la
bibliothèque je suis complètement
passionné je découvre un univers que je
connaissais pas en étudiant la musique
du moyen âge jusqu'à aujourd'hui et en
amont à cette école tout le monde devait
prendre au moins une fois un cours de
direction orchestrale on pouvait pas y
échapper il fallait faire un moment et
c'était un cours qui étaient un peu
redoutée par tous temps le disais il va
falloir que j'y aille mon dieu sauve et
moi donc moi j'y vais hop je veux dire
qu'est ce qui va se passer
au final j'adore je trouve ça super puis
à fond dedans donc mes professeurs me
disent t'as qu'à essayer d'en faire ta
deuxième c'était donc je me dis wow est
pourquoi pas on va voir
donc je passe une audition parce qu'il
fallait passer une audition pour entrer
dans cette spéciale qu'elle avait été
pris sur 5000 c'est un peu tendu
et je suis prise bush super donc je me
retrouve avec les quatre autres en étant
la seule personne qui a pas du tout en
bas grande classique donc au final
c'était c'était plutôt très enrichissant
donc je finis mes études et vers la fin
de mes études je me dis bon deuxième
problème qu'est ce que je vais faire
maintenant parce que j'ai pas envie de
refaire des études assez ça commence à
faire un peu long maintenant donc je me
dis bah il va falloir que je trouve un
peu des références dans le monde des
orchestres qui travaille dans le milieu
dans lequel je veux travailler
c'est-à-dire les musiques actuelles
l'électro la pop le rock la folk les
sessions d'enregistrement radio musique
de film etc bref tous les orchestres qui
ne font pas du tout une musique
classique et là je commence à absolument
harcelé par e-mail le chef d'orchestre
du métro alors qu'asda 0 hollande qu'une
grande référence dans ces orcas là il a
le malheur de répondre un jour j'ai dit
ah ah ah
et en gros je le convent slash force de
me laisser venir pour un apprentissage
et je débarque en hollande et je fais
une saison complète avec le métropole
orcas en tant que assistante du chef et
j'ai aussi la grande chance de être
hébergé sheila manager de cet orchestre
donc là j'apprends comment un orchestre
fonctionne de l'intérieur via l les
notions économiques administratives etc
qui sont extrêmement importantes et via
lui aux répétitions je vois vraiment
c'est quoi la réalité d'être à la tête
d'un orchestre plus que professionnelle
les réalités de temps de budget etc etc
etc
donc après cet apprentissage rentrer à
paris
et là j'ai plein d'idées j'appelle de
mes copains je leur dit écoutez on va
faire un orchestre c'est tout on fait
juste le faire ils me disent oui oui
donc on commence un peu à faire des
listes d'idées quoi du brainstorming
d'artistes avec lesquels on voulait
travailler exclusivement la scène
indépendante parisienne donc dans les
musiques actuelles et on se retrouve à
avoir un rendez vous au théâtre du
châtelet puis sais pas si vous
connaissez c'est un endroit très très
beaux appareils en salle très
prestigieuse hu à la base on voulait
juste rencontré le régisseur pour qu'ils
nous expliquent comment amplifier
meilleur essai économique
un orchestre de 20 musiciens quand on
arrive on commence à lui par avait on
lui explique notre projet nous dit ah
vous savez quoi le directeur et là on va
les voir on fait ou d'accord donc tac
tac tac tac ont monté les marches on se
retrouve dans un bureau absolument
énorme avec une table encore plus grande
et le directeur en bout de table nous
dit bombe a expliqué nouveau projet on
lui parle il fait eu d'accord bah vous
allez faire un concert ici le mois
prochain ont fait super à ce point là on
n'avait ni orchestre musiciens y avait
collaboré mais c'est pas grave il faut
toujours dire oui et raimondi maire
d'après toujours comme ça et au final
nos premières dates pas s'arrêter au
théâtre du châtelet sold out avec deux
des artistes avec lesquels on voulait
plus travailler qui est en haut de notre
liste
donc on l'a fait et un an et demi plus
tard on avait travaillé avec absolument
tous les artistes avec lesquels on
voulait travailler
donc ça a été une réussite d'abord
musical mais aussi humaine donc après ça
il s'écoule depuis sa tête depuis cet
événement il s'est écoulé environ deux
ans je pense maintenant à ma grande
surprise je fais de plus en plus de
composition de musiques de films là je
travaille sur un documentaire qui est
produit par disney qui sort bientôt
je travaille avec un orchestre très très
très haut niveau qui s'appelle le sio
walcott n'a pas vocation qui pour la
petite histoire était un peu mon
orchestre rêver je pensais que j'allais
bosser avec eux dans dix ans maintenant
je le fais c'est très cool je fais des
arrangements pour plein d'artistes
différents comme etienne daho et j'ai un
disque qui sort cette année
donc la conclusion enfin si je devais
conclure et résumé c'est que pour moi je
pense que dans la vie ce qui est
vraiment important c'est pas de se dire
qu'on sera bon qu'à une chose et qu'on
est bons qu'à une chose il faut toujours
faire exactement ce qu'on veut faire et
le plus important dans tout ça c'est
qu'il faut absolument croire en soi même
il faut que ça soit une évidence que
vous allez y arriver il faut aussi s'en
donner les moyens de par le travail et
croyez-moi quand vous allez faire
exactement
vous voulez faire vous allez je l'espère
comme moi attendre une espèce de
sérénité et de joie de vivre
je sais pas ce que je vais faire l'année
prochaine mais j'ai hâte d'être à
l'année prochaine
donc je vous encourage à devenir la
personne la plus heureuse que vous
connaissez merci
[Musique]